I'd want to be in the room and those
early bottled water meetings yeah like
people were like get the [ __ ] out of
here it's free it's free it's in our
kitchen for free
[Music]
warning daily be ATM in my office
hi guy yo some coffee that's through a
meeting in scape an incredible
meditation studio and app that I
invested in nice and quiet in the office
which is actually not nice because I
hate silence it freaks me the [ __ ] out
but you learn F dudes sweat shirt
collars easily bribed every day
oh I did have this thought this is great
yeah yeah you guys put it in there yes I
love it why it's trying to make me super
fat you did please delicious yummy let's
go ahead get out of here you praise all
of it alright good to see ya hey better
podcast are winning its underpriced
that's it it's just very simple it's
very simple so so I you know I hear you
on the library I'm just putting that
aside for a second I'm trying to be
practical
what would I do if I was running this
business I think you should really
debate the podcast I think your you
would crush it wouldn't matter and I
think the guests would matter a mint you
know I just I don't know saying it was
amazing when you guys said New York
Times like what went through my body
which is my god
literally what went through my body is
like okay I just the amount of impact
which the kid sitting in your studio I'm
putting it on his Instagram meaning
versus the entire New York Times article
they're not even in the same
stratosphere it's just quite scary you
know which Kylie Jenner is getting paid
right now for a post on Instagram and
snapchat do you know what the latest
price is 1.3 million dollars for a
singular clothes so crush to talk and
new talent search button Shazam new
talents credit union
Mitt Romney rely show me who I am okay
it comes down to content distribution
content distribution and buying
underpriced attention underpriced
attention is Facebook underpriced
attention is Instagram influencers and
underpriced attention is podcasting
Alexis skills everything works that
billboard works out there it's
overpriced it shouldn't be $7,000 a
month that's all chill man I bet you
feel like a genius really really can't
wait till we start selling oxygen
because it's a foregone conclusion if
you just look at the trend I'd want to
be in the room and those early bottled
water meetings like people were like get
the [ __ ] out of here
it's free it's free it's in our kitchen
for free it's a four it's a foregone
conclusion and it's a big market oh my
god how are you we are living through
such a big shift of the maturity of the
internet itself like all of us have
lived through this internet thing um
it's just very young I you know if I can
if you could lead with anything at a
macro is how early this really is and
like how it impacts supermarkets or
varsity jackets or real estate or
lending it's going to continue to
compound and the one thing I want to
make sure everybody realizes is that
uber and Amazon and Airbnb are the
previews they're not the anomalies every
single person here is going to be
affected by it in a meaningful way more
so than they're affected by it now and I
think the key is you need to extract
value out of it and don't allow it to
tech extract value out of you I'll tell
you this is a long-winded answer to this
it's fine
it can't be half pregnant people want to
do thing if you get to the self-help
stop people like to do things like me
with this part cut out
I just eat [ __ ] 24/7 365 people don't
want to
all right cool I'll be back all right
I'll figure it out you got it
[Music]
I'm just taking the piss give me a
second
the problem is the content has to be
contextual to the platform Pete you keep
releasing I don't like things that take
a piece of content and distribute them
is because the creative is not
contextual to where it's being deployed
people using social media as
distribution instead of as a native
place to story tell when you put a piece
of content to somebody in Germany why
Bock reign first well you have to
understand the psychology of a German
user on Twitter before you even get to
what you're going to put on there if you
just use HootSuite because it lets you
post on all these platforms in one shot
you've lost the purpose of what we're
trying to accomplish you've achieved
putting a piece of content on 47 web
sites efficiently who gives a [ __ ] if
you didn't sell any packages cool I love
you guys let's take a quick photo
superfast
[Music]
alright guys heading out I've got a
couple of drinks meetings bunch of
cancellations it's been a weird day
kind of weird cancellation run exactly
or life is good
bunch of new clients that you couldn't
show that we can write in client times
500 business pitch big one huge [ __ ]
company then we got a shot excited
running intermedia what I do what else
do they ask us on Facebook is doing
sadhana
yeah I like podcasts really good so
let's do that for you
I believe in trading attention and I
think podcasting is grossly underpriced
and I think all of you should start a
podcast in the same way that all of you
are starting blogs don't do it
figure it out it's even easier it's your
voice you don't have to be handsome
[Music]